jackson ist von allem eine frage aber
ist ob du schon mal daran gedacht hast
du für ein überleben zu drehen weil das
wieder von canon hat sie voll
interessanter und ich bin der meinung es
gibt künstler die sind weniger
interessant und ich will jetzt auch
filme argument ich hoffe meine frage ist
nicht so abwegig ich habe mein bestes
geben und ich freue mich total auf das
album ich zähle die tage und an meiner
wand steht mein lieblingszitat von
independence erfolgs musst du hast du
fliegst du musst ja na danke für deine
frage um danke für dein sehr schönes t
shirt was du anders wirklich schön wie
du selbst selber sogar zu recht
gestellten hast auch eine sehr schöne
ein sehr schönes poster an der wand
wie gesagt ein film über mein leben drin
leider kann ich das nicht mit meinem
iphone drehen sonst hätte ich bestimmt
schon gemacht werden wir auf jeden fall
spaß machen aber da braucht man halt die
zeit und leute die investieren und ein
filmteam und universe little und alle
möglichen anderen leute und das haben
wir jetzt im moment nicht erst mal musik
und weil sie ihnen vielleicht mit 40
anfrage anraff meinst du kannst bald im
idealfall camorra und 3.0 so mixen mit
damit es jedem gefällt hast du dir
darüber mal gedanken gemacht ich habe
tatsächlich schon darüber nachgedacht so
ich habe darüber nachgedacht wie ich das
mischen können das ist mir gefällt und
dass ich nichts von beiden vermische
aber wie gesagt jetzt erst mal das 30
alben
dann sehe ich meine weiter was passiert
hallo hallo christa ich habe hier fragen
ein erster frage wäre waffen deine ziele
für weitere musikalische laufbahn
frage 2 wäre du hast in früheren
interviews angesprochen dass eventuell
haft kamera und kraft treten künstler
machen willst gibt es in der hinsicht
etwas neues oder müssen dieser immer
noch nicht ganz sicher
rang drei wäre was hörst du in deiner
freizeit schulmusik und was hältst du
von dem ganzen hype um crowe und wann
gibt es was neues von firma kipp zu
hören das war es von mir
hey also meine ziele für die zukunft wie
gesagt man muss hoch schießen um an den
bestimmten punkt zu kommen der ungefähr
dort in der richtung ist ich weiß noch
nicht sagen wir so ich mache weiter ich
gebe alles und mal sehen wie weit kommt
natürlich sind meine ziele weit oben
aber man darf es nicht aussprechen sonst
kommen sie nicht weiteres raff kamera
und rav 30 zusammenzubringen ist
natürlich etwas
ich beschäftige mich natürlich seitdem
seite geburt von 0 sehr mit diesem thema
wie denn diese beiden ziele vielleicht
zusammenfinden könnten was neues gibt es
noch nicht wirklich will ich bin jetzt
gerade noch voll in der arbeit von hoch
zwei und eine dritte frage war der
höhepunkt der hypo hat mich eigentlich
überhaupt nicht gestört ich feiere sogar
crowe und diese ganze sache die da mit
sich gebracht hat das einzige was mich
stört ist dass der jetzt in minor
release woche liest und das natürlich
meine charts effekt aber ansonsten finde
ich das eigentlich was die ganzen jungs
auch von chimperator machen gut und es
hat etwas neues gekommen hat sein laptop
gemacht und ist der ort wo maschine so
zu sagen ich würde das selber nicht im
auto pumpen
aber ich respektiere das auf jeden fall
sehr viel mehr als andere leute die da
vielleicht musik machten die ein
bisschen passende aber zu meiner ist
aber finde ich finde ich eigentlich gar
nicht schlecht
die letzte frage war sehr clever kids
auch eine junge bin ich unglaublich
feiern also ich muss sogar sagen in den
letzten jahren das größte talent was mir
untergekommen ist vor allem mit 16
jahren und es gibt auf jeden fall
neuigkeiten die ich weiß um die harmonie
war es der gerade da sitzt die er
vielleicht danach wissen wird aber
leider gar nicht so nicht verraten aber
auf jeden fall zukunft empfiehlt 92
fragt er
hast du noch kontakt zu chakuza wenn ja
werdet ihr mal wieder songs zusammen
machen finde ihr beiden macht die beste
musik und ihr werdet euch perfekt
ergänzen
ich danke dir vielmals ich habe sehr
guten kontakt zu yakuza sogar ich habe
erst gestern gesehen
wir haben auch songs zusammen gemacht
einen song ist sogar auf der premium
edition von meinem album drauf und wie
gesagt chakuza war der der mich nach
berlin geholt habe super typ
perfekt geschafft zwei fragen und zwar
irgendwie kommt es zur depressiven
stimmung in vielen der songs hat das was
mit drogenkonsum oder mit deiner
kindheit zu tun und die zweite frage ist
von wo du deine heitz gelten hat denn
die sehen richtig geilen aus das war es
bei mir
jojo das sind zwei sehr gute fragen und
zwar die erste frage wo meine depressive
stimmung in vielen songs herkommt das
ding ist ich bin aufgewachsen schon
einen sehr düsteren ort das waren sehr
viele haben dort wo ich war
die musik der politische musik die mich
geprägt hat war immer sehr sehr traurig
und da habe ich meinen künstlerischen
touch quasi natürlich immer in das
melancholische zu gehen und mein leben
war natürlich nicht immer rosig und wenn
du sehr viel blödsinn erlebst und sehr
viel grau ist siehst dann werden deine
songs dadurch auch grauer und daher
kommt das halt aber wie gesagt man muss
ja immer kompensieren und vielleicht
ändert sich das eines tages von den
drogen also ich glaube nicht dass das
jetzt von den drogen kommt obwohl ich
auch auf jeden fall eine vergangenheit
diesbezüglich habe aber kommt glaube ich
nicht da man die andere frage zu diesen
halsketten
diese hätten das freut mich dass mich
jemand fragt und zwar die werden von
denen man das glaube ich auf das mikro
gerät ist diese halsketten hier dich
immer trage sind die sogenannten kdl
ketten krieger des lichts das sind
ketten von einem sehr sehr guten freund
und
auch ein sehr inspirative mensch
sozusagen der mir diese karte geschenkt
hat als persönliches geschenk die hat 88
perlen die steht für die 88 tempel und
das ist eine kette die quasi für mich
bedeutet auf der seite des lichts zu
gehen also nicht im schatten sondern auf
der guten seite
und deswegen gibt es diese kette jetzt
auch nicht irgendwie zu kaufen und wegen
was das ist eine persönliche ein
persönliches geschenk das ich und enge
freunde von diesen menschen tragen und
wie gesagt ich hoffe meine frage ist
damit kann sollte meine frage am raff
3.0
woher hast du deinen so besonderen bezug
zur musik viele rapper picken sich
einfach beats und treppen aber bei dir
merkt man dass jeder effekt und jeder
ton in deinen liedern von dir dort genau
so gewollt wurde das macht deine musik
so besonders aber woher kommt dieser
perfektionismus
vielleicht kommt es dann meine mutter
war opernsängerin ich war als sie schon
die stimmübungen gemacht hat in ihrem
bauch also ich bin geboren als eine
tonleiter und für mich ist musik das ist
alles und wenn ich etwas kann dann ist
es wirklich arrangieren und hat den song
so auseinander würfeln dass das dass ich
den wirklichen den einzelteilen habe und
dann wieder so zusammensetzen das alles
perfekt passt also ich setze mich sehr
sehr sehr viel damit auseinander
und ich danke für das kompliment auf
jeden fall und muss halt sagen es ist
wie gesagt bei mir ein krankhafter ein
krankhafter man kann sagen fast
perfektionismus mit dem ich auch nie
wirklich zufrieden bin aber es freut
mich wenn jemand findet dass das symbol
krasses jojo rafaela tschöp raf camora
kraft drei punkten und raps vater lka
der aeg mir fällt nichts mehr ein alter
was geht ab meine frage bezieht sich auf
deine hooks und zwar ob du bock hast
wieder welche auf französisch zu bringen
oder mit dem gedanken spielt weil ich
auch zweierbob verstanden aber die hand
deswegen dieser jojo man mit den eine
million hektar ist sehr sehr witzige
frage wie du sie gestellt das ist
wirklich sehr lustig musste hier lachen
auf dieser gauck auf jeden fall
bezüglich mann wuchs mit dem
französischen hooks habe ich aus dem
grund eigentlich aufgehört dass sie
niemand verstanden und manchmal habe ich
wuchs gesungen über das leben ist
schwierig und man sollte sich am riemen
reißen und dann hat ein feature partner
drüber gewölbt grüne schuhe ist in das
beste auf der welt und es hat halt dann
nicht zusammengepasst und wie gesagt das
ist halt ein bisschen für mich dass es
so wie wenn man einfach munition in den
himmel schießen würde was ich meine das
ding ist ich habe natürlich darüber
wieder nachgedacht französisch zu singen
allerdings dann nur komplette
französische songs die ich in frankreich
veröffentlichen kann
rumpf als jetzt vielleicht der eine beat
oder der eines ankommt wo es wirklich
perfekt passt dann soll es geschehen
aber ansonsten habe ich das erst mal auf
eis gelegt auf eis gelegt